ihr zugeschaltet ist jetzt martin hagen
fdp fraktionschef in bayern
wir wollen über diesen fall jetzt einmal
noch mal sprechen ja guten tag herr
hagen bayerische polizisten vor ort auf
den corona dem es auf der bühne als
redner was sagen sie dazu
grundsätzlich haben natürlich auch
polizisten das recht auf freie
meinungsäusserung auf politische
betätigung auch sie dürfen natürlich an
versammlung teilnehmen und auch dort
sprechen als privatpersonen
sie sind aber zur mäßigung gehalten als
beamte und vor allem sie dürfen dort
eben nicht als polizisten auftreten und
das war das problem dass die betroffenen
beamten hier nicht als privatpersonen
sich ausgewiesen haben sondern explizit
als polizei angehörige angekündigt
wurden und als auch in ihren reden noch
mal betont haben
das heißt die nehmen sich die autorität
die ihr amt ihnen gibt und verbreiten
damit dann ihre politische meinung und
das ist problematisch sprich ich muss da
noch mal nachhaken wenn die männer
deutlich gemacht hätten dass sie als
privatperson dort vor ort sind dann wäre
es okay gewesen wenn die männer als
privatpersonen ihre politische meinung
dort kundtun und die nicht extremistisch
oder gegen unsere verfassung unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
gerichtet ist dann ist das zu tolerieren
wenn sie es explizit als polizisten tun
und wenn sie obendrein auch noch rechte
verschwörungs mythen bedient oder gar
nicht verfassungsfeindlich äußern ich
weiß nicht ob das in diesem fall
passiert ist dann ist es ein problem und
dann hat es natürlich auch
dienstrechtliche konsequenzen
es ist aber wichtig zu sagen es sind
wirklich ganz wenige einzelfälle wir
haben ja gestern in berlin auch das
gegenteil erlebt wir haben polizeibeamte
erlebt die sich wirklich unter großem
persönlichen einsatz mutig den
demonstranten entgegengestellt haben die
versucht haben den reichstag zu stürmen
das waren ja über 100 leute mit reichs
flaggen also wirklich rechtsextremisten
reichs bürger die dort versucht haben in
die herzkammer unserer parlamentarischen
demokratie vorzudringen und die drei
polizeibeamten die sich dort dieser
zahlenmäßig überlegenen meute
entgegengestellt haben und sie davon
abgehalten haben den reichstag zu
betreten
wir haben wirklich einen großartigen job
gemacht die verdienen auch unseren dank
in diesen zeiten in denen polizisten ja
häufig auch kritik hören müssen und ich
finde
der bundespräsident sollte diese beamten
auch
die bundesverdienstkreuz während sie
sprachen sahen wir noch mal die bilder
erzählen wir den polizisten im einsatz
der nicht mal mehr zeit hatte seinen
helm auf zu ziehen und dort den
reichstag verteidigt hatte gegen die
demonstranten die versucht haben das
gebäude zu stürmen
wie ist ihre bilanz des gestrigen tages
wenn sie sie wenn sie diese bilder vor
dem reichstag sehen
diese bilder sind sinnbildlich für
unsere wehrhafte demokratie das was
diese drei beamten dort getan haben sich
nämlich mutig den leuten
entgegenzustellen die versuchen den
reichstag zu stürmen
das ist ein sinnbild unserer wehrhaften
demokratie dass es so weit kommen konnte
dass hunderte menschen polizei
absperrungen durchbrechen dass sie bis
zur treppe des reichstags vordringen
können das weist natürlich schon auch
auf versäumnisse hin beim
sicherheitskonzept da wird sicherlich
die politik in berlin einiges
aufzuarbeiten haben ja die aufgabe der
politik besteht auch darin wir haben
darüber öfter gesprochen sich die frage
zu stellen wie kann man diesen mix an
menschen er gestern in berlin auf die
straße ging auffangen was kann die
politik hier tun
ich denke man muss zunächst mal
differenzieren es ist ja wohl eine sehr
bunte mischung wir haben esoteriker und
hippies wir haben rechtsextremisten und
reichs bürger wir haben corona leuten
und impfgegner wir haben menschen die
dort vor der russischen botschaft putin
gehuldigt haben
das heißt es ist nicht über einen kamm
zu scheren es ist auch nicht ganz klar
zu greifen
es ist nicht alles eine politische
richtung aus der das kommt und
sicherlich sind auch bürger darunter die
einfach nur bedenken haben die legitime
kritik an der korona politik der
bundesregierung äußern
das heißt nicht alle über einen kamm
scheren aber schon klar machen wer bei
versammlungen steht bei den
reichskriegsflagge geschwenkt werden bei
denen leute wie attila hildmann die
wildesten antisemitischen
verschwörungstheorien skandieren
wer dort mit demonstriert der macht sich
natürlich mit der sache gemein und dass
man solche leute zurückholt ins
demokratische spektrum da habe ich
ehrlich gesagt auch wenig hoffnung aber
das ist auch eine sehr sehr kleine
minderheit wir sehen ja dass der große
teil unserer bevölkerung diese
demonstration auch ablehnt
martin hahn fdp fraktionschef in bayern
fordert das bundesverdienstkreuz für die
polizisten die gestern im einsatz waren
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch
dann gehen alles gute